bonjour dixième numéro de café politique
sur tv fils les élus qui viennent ici au
bistrot du théâtre à montigny le
bretonneux pour évoquer les principaux
dossiers qui les occupent mais aussi
parler de leur parcours aujourd'hui
grégory est resté bonjour bonjour vous
êtes le maire ump de meaux repas est lui
un peu plus de 30 en mars dernier 49,25
% des voix dans une triangulaire qui
vous opposait une liste composée d'élus
de l'ancienne majorité de centre gauche
et puis m liste socialiste également
enfants de la ville de maurepas il est
arrivé comme un repas avoir écouté j'y
suis pratiquement nez parce que les
moyens pas de l'hôpital à maurepas mais
j'ai toujours vécu à maurepas j'ai
grandi et maurepas j'ai fréquenté les
écoles de maurepas à l'école de la
tutelle à malmö donne le collège louis
pergaud donc j'ai fait toute ma
scolarité et j'y vis toujours donc je me
sens bien et pourtant quand vous avez
décidé de vous lancer avec cette
légitimité de maurepas gyan conquête du
poste de maire de la ville n'a pas été
si facile que ça sur votre route il y
avait pierre leguérinel il était adjoint
de georges mougeot le maire divers
gauche qui était en poste depuis 89 qui
a décidé lui de ne pas se représenter
aux derniers scrutins pire le guérinel
qui quittent quelques mois avant le
scrutin la majorité et qui veut porter
une liste ump udi et lavaud famille
politique se divise vous l'avez vécu
comment cette période c'était une
période compliquée parce que c'est vrai
que vous l'avez vous l'avez rappelé les
zigzags
de l'ancien pour maire-adjoint de
georges mougeot est évidemment moi je
croyais j'avais la vérité avec moi et je
croyais en ce que je faisais à l'époque
et évidemment je crois que l'amour
passion m'ont donné les raisons de toute
façon parce qu'ils ont tranché ils ont
tranché pour le candidat du renouveau
celui avec son équipe qui fait de la
politique avec avec le choeur avec
sincérité avec honnêteté et voilà on
m'attend c'est du passé mais la campagne
a été difficile malgré tout parce que ça
laisse des traces parce que au sein même
de nos salles et olivier actionnaires
c'est mon investiture au tout début
l'ump qui revenu vers vous après pendant
votre absolument vous a proposé de faire
une fusion avec pierre le guérinel vous
n'en avez pas voulu vous êtes resté avec
votre liste vous aviez composer j'étais
persuadé que je gagnerais sans alliance
parce que j'étais persuadé que pierre le
guérinel partirait à gauche comme il
l'avait fait en 2008 au second tour et
voilà les résultats sont là ça a été une
campagne difficile alors je ne suis pas
rancunier par nature mais je n'oublie
pas n'oubliez pas ça veut dire que ça
laisse des traces ça laisse des traces
même dans l'équipe ça laisse des traces
j'ai quand même été traîné devant les
tribunaux pour me faire retirer un logo
de l'ump je peux vous dire que c'est
quand même un épisode qui est difficile
à vivre et ça je n'oublierai jamais en
effet l'ump c'est votre famille
politique vous y adhérez à l'âge de 16
ans oui pourquoi l'ump pour que
l'oxygène aussi on peut alors déjà je me
suis engagé en politique j'étais dans
mon salon je regardais la télé et puis
je mens peu plus très bien ce que
c'était mais
j'avais vu un reportage sur une
situation en france et je m'étais dit ça
peut faut que ça change et pour changer
les choses il faut avoir le pouvoir et
pouvoir le pouvoir il faut s'engager en
politique il faut militer il faut aller
voter et donc c'est ce que j'ai fait je
me suis engagé au sein de l'ump parce
que évidemment je fais des valeurs de
droite à l'autorité le mérite le travail
et donc voilà tout est parti de là
c'était clair dès le début le choix de
la famille oui oui c'était l'ump mais
ces serments ouais vous aviez envie de
faire carrière politique déjà à cette
époque hélas aujourd'hui est ce que vous
avez envie de faire carrière dans la
politique j'avais déjà à l'époque
j'avais envie détenir de maurepas parce
que comme j'y suis né je suis natif de
la ville et donc je suis enraciné dans
ma ville et donc j'avais envie de porter
des justement des projets pour les mois
passent bien et d'améliorer ma ville
donc voila c'était en tout cas
l'ambition que j'avais à l'époque et
aujourd'hui donc cette carrière
politique là vous étiez remplaçant
suppléant sur les élections
départementales donc en cas de
désistement des têtes de liste vous
prendrez la place au conseil
départemental
c'est comme ça que vous allez progresser
continuer en politique alors chaque jour
son temps je suis jeune mère ça fait un
an que je suis élu j'ai 32 ans je ne
suis pas comme beaucoup d'hommes
politiques ils sont déjà dans la presse
moi je suis dans le présent j'agis
maintenant et voilà j'ai tout l'avenir
devant moi en général quand on se lance
tout de même en politique on pense aussi
à la presse parce que retourner à une
vie plus classique en dehors de la
politique c'est toujours un petit peu
plus compliqué j'imagine que vous pensez
déjà ne serait ce qu un deuxième mandat
ou ce poste de conseiller départemental
voire plus je n'y pense pas être
conseiller départemental j'étais
suppléant ça me suffit bien il ya
l'entrée dans la communauté
d'agglomération bientôt donc je serai
certainement vice président donc ça va
être une charge de travail
supplémentaire
mr plus vice président d'une communauté
d'agglomération de plus de 100000
habitants je pense que c'est déjà pas
mal mais on en parlait de
l'agglomération dans la seconde partie
de cette émission votre formation
professionnelle cadres dans la
communication publique et territoriale
ce choix s'était allié avec ses volontés
politiques parce que vous avez été aussi
responsable du côté des longs cours vous
avez travaillé avec jean michel brousse
oui tout à fait alors mon métier
origines ses communicants voilà j'ai
fait des études de publicité de
communication publique et territoriale
et politique et donc c'est vrai que
voilà je me suis engagé également dans
la communication auprès d'un maire qui a
des résultats qui dans la ville d'à côté
j'ai eu l'honneur de travailler avec lui
j'ai beaucoup appris à ses côtés et puis
voilà presse j'ai eu mon avenir à
politique à côté qui n'a jamais été
influencé par mon travail professionnel
mais en tout cas
je ne regrette pas ces années mais ça a
permis de développer un réseau tout de
même oui c'est important politique de
créer un réseau de créer une amitié même
d amitié et je pense que maintenant ce
sont des forces elle qui me sont utiles
tous les jours de travailler avec des
mères aux alentours avec qui je suis ami
ça a été un soutien de poids jean michel
fourgous dont les différentes il m'a
toujours soutenu comme d'autres maires
des villes aux alentours mais c'est vrai
que jean michel fourgous a toujours été
à mes côtés et j'ai toujours été à ses
côtés également dans ces combats je
reviens juste sur votre formation de
deux secondes vous dire où travailler
dans la communication c'est votre
formation de base politique
communication la même chose il faut
savoir habiller les choses enrober les
choses pour faire nationalité a
absolument il ya des stratégies de
communication en mettre en place mais il
faut toujours dire la vérité voilà c'est
ça l'état dans la manipulation hérité
d'une communication n'y a pas de journée
dans l'année dans la vérité toute vérité
n'est pas bonne à dire forcément au bon
moment enfin en tout il faut dire les
choses au bon moment pardon mais il faut
les dire avec avec justesse et avec avec
recul sur tout mais croque hull mais il
faut toujours dire la vérité aux
consultants inc la communication une
formation communication ça aide pour la
politique ça aide pour la forêt dit
paula très utile je reviens sur votre
âge 32 ans vous l'avez dit 31 ans au
moment de mettre de l'élection en tant
que maire ne meurt pas c'est assez jeune
finalement pour pour un maire c'est un
peu le renouveau ça a été difficile de
vous imposer dans votre famille
politique oui c'est vrai que la jeunesse
a du mal dans notre pays a persévéré et
justement on persévère quand on croit
quand on croit en soi même et quand on
croit avec son équipe quand on croit en
nos idées et donc il faut se lancer
voilà tous les jeunes qui veulent
s'engager en politique il faut y aller
parce que c'est la seule manière de
changer les choses si on ne s'engage pas
les choses ne changeront pas il faut
aller aussi voter et quand on est dans
une situation telle que là on la connaît
en ce moment en france il faut s'engager
pour changer les choses il ya des
familles politiques où il est plus
difficile que dans d'autres de s'engager
de prendre de la place de prendre sa
place lorsqu'on est jeune à l'ump est ce
que c'était je pense que c'est non non
je pense que c'est parce que je vois là
je regarde aussi ce qui se passe en
france dans les autres partis politiques
que je il ya des partis politiques qui
sont très jeunes et où c'est plus facile
mais ils ont pratiquement aucune chance
d'être élu même s'ils défendent de
nouvelles idées ce qui est important
également
mais on a un système qui en france qui
fait qu'on a du mal quand même la
jeunesse a du mal à percer vrai même si
c'est un peu tendance à changer parce
que les concitoyens ont envie aussi de
renouveau et on le voit au travers des
résultats des dernières élections ils
ont envie de voir de nouvelles têtes de
nouvelles idées de nouvelles approches
de changer le système dans lequel on est
et la jeunesse doit porter ces messages
l'ump votre famille politique vous
l'avez choisi des saisons et vous étiez
sûr de votre choix il nous l'avait dit
tout à l'heure aujourd'hui quel regard
vous portez en tant que jeune au sein de
l'ump l'ump va bien va mieux aujourd'hui
lé in pé va beaucoup mieux depuis que
nicolas sarkozy a repris la présidence
du parti la famille est uni maintenant
il faut travailler le fond ça sonne
cependant apprécié nicolas savoye c'est
tout à fait oui quand j'ai été
responsable des jeunes de l'ump à
l'époque puisque j'étais responsable des
jeunes de mattia conception j'avais
participé à préparer sa campagne
présidentielle de 2007 non j'avais
travaillé à ses côtés donc j'ai beaucoup
aussi appris avec lui et ça reste un
grand homme d'état donc c'est votre
candidat pour 2017 c'est mon candidat
pour 2011 2017 on nous dit l'ump va
mieux et est ce que l'ump aujourd'hui a
fait des choix clairs et je pense
notamment face au front national
est-ce que les choix qui sont pris par
l'ump aujourd'hui les déclarations qui
sont faites récemment christian estrosi
maire de nice qui sera candidat aux
régionales sur ce secteur parler des
cinquièmes colonnes de l'islamo fascisme
qui font la guerre en france alors là il
marche clairement sur les plates bandes
du front national parce que c'est
nécessaire pour l'ump aujourd'hui de
faire ça
je pense que
le vote front national doit être entendu
il ya une désespérance dans notre pays
on le voit encore aujourd'hui avec les
résultats du chômage qui explose donc on
a des concitoyens qui sont dans la
souffrance et donc il faut pas jeter
ceux qui votent front national c'est
surtout un vote de désespérance de
désespoir donc il faut leur parler mais
il faut correctement leur parler c'est
en année sur les terres de l'extrême
droite je me refuse totalement
mais en tout cas il faut entendre le
message de ceux qui désespèrent de la
politique comme ceux qui s'abstiennent
d'ailleurs c'est important que ceux qui
s'abstiennent il y en a beaucoup plus
que ceux qui votent front national il
faut en tout cas d entendre et répondre
à leurs attentes et je pense que le
renouveau la jeune génération en tout
cas peut y répondre mais les
déclarations de christian estrosi par
exemple au sein de l'ump ça a dit viser
un petit peu ça a choqué certains est ce
que vous vous en faites partie vous avez
été choqué où vous trouvez ça normal non
je ne partage pas ses propos
naturellement je ne préfère pas
m'engager dans dents
dans ce discours naturellement moi qui
suis plutôt quelqu'un de modérer vous
n'aimez pas trop d'ailleurs les conflits
ce genre de territoire la non vous vous
engagez là dessus il faut faire un
consensus en politique ça c'est un peu
votre wii je n'ai je n'aime pas les
choses qui vante voilà je pense qu'il
faut faire souvent est un consensus on
est dans une société qui est beaucoup
fracture est divisée donc il faut aussi
rassembler il faut avoir un discours qui
soit porteur et qu'ils soient entendus
par la majorité des français et je le
fais au niveau de ma commune à maurepas
ou voilà je suis pas un maire de droite
je suis mère de tous les maux croisiens
et c'est important voilà j'ai un message
aussi qui rassembleur et je parle à tout
le monde même ceux qui n'ont pas voté
pour moi une dernière question
concernant l'ump puis on passera à la
seconde partie de cette émission pour
remplacer le nom de l'ump on parle des
républicains rassemblement pour le
peuple de france c'était plutôt le choix
de nadine morano vous préférez lequel
revient à lusaka moi j'aime ce club et à
leur public un ce que je suis
républicain j'aspire aux valeurs de la
république donc c'est un message fort
mais au delà d'un nom il faut du fond et
voilà maintenant on a du boulot le café
politique se poursuit après cette courte
pause
seconde partie du café politique et nous
allons toujours avec vous grégory est
resté parler de vos projets à présent
pour cette ville de maurepas maurepas
village jusque dans les années 60 puis
rapidement urbanisées et qui compte
aujourd'hui de près de 19 mille
habitants nous en avons rencontré à
quelques-uns écouter ce qu'ils pensent
de la commune moi je suis contente de ma
ville je suis depuis là depuis 72 et
j'en suis très contente on a quand même
bon il ya des problèmes bien sûr pour le
moment avec la piscine à l'est plus
depuis quelques temps que je faisais
beaucoup plus propre et beaucoup une
amélioration dans tous pour les services
pour tous et puis c'est agréable à vivre
aussi on n'est pas né pour génial et
c'est quand même pas de bruit mais très
tranquille il ya tous les commerces
vraiment qu'ils sont parfaits et le
point négatif on nous avait parlé qu'ils
allaient monter un cinéma du côté
d'auchan est en fait je crois que ça va
tomber à l'eau et c'est dommage je
trouve que je suis très contente d'être
ici c'est une ville agréable les pilotes
et puis bien entretenus sur tout il n'y
a pas mal d'activités on a un bon choix
c'est tranquille
oui moi je suis content d'être amour pas
avec de nouveaux maires la piscine
fermée peut-être
ça c'est dommage surtout quand il fait
beau maurepas ville agréable ça revient
souvent ville propre c'est au bout des
agréables après un an de mandat on va
tout de même évoqué un dossier de la
piscine dossier également du cinéma et
qui ont été évoquées par les habitants
mais pour l'instant on a le sentiment
que tout va bien à bord pas la preuve
moi je suis content voilà quand je relis
mort passe bien je suis heureux avec mon
équipe c'est vrai que depuis un an on a
la lourde tâche voilà de renouveler la
ville de mieux entretenir d'entretenir
deux bâtiments les espaces verts
également et on en voit la preuve
aujourd'hui avec les témoignages les
gens qui apprécient vos premiers choix
vous êtes élu depuis un an malgré tout
il ya un héritage aussi celui de la
majorité l'ancienne majorité divers
gauche en seulement même socialistes à
la gauche qui détenait la ville depuis
1989 aujourd'hui vous voulez faire table
rase du passé justement où vous
l'assumez une partie de cet héritage et
vous vous dites que tout n'est pas à
jeter oui tout n'est pas à jeter il ya
des choses positives qui ont été fait
malgré tout je récupère quand même ce
qu'on appelle une d'être cachés qui
n'est pas dans les comptes c'est-à-dire
l'entretien des bâtiments qui n'a
pratiquement jamais été fait et on le
voit on en parlera tout à l'heure avec
la piscine je rénove également
l'ensemble des écoles on en a 17 qui
sont dans un mauvais état donc tout ça
fait que évidemment je récupère
une gestion qui n'est pas celle que
j'aurais souhaité récupérer et en tout
cas c'est très difficile dans le
contexte actuel avec la baisse des
finances publiques des dotations d'état
de d'engager tous les projets en même
temps tout faire des choix sur
l'augmentation des impôts parce que j'ai
voté mon budget il ya quelques jours
soit augmenter les impôts locaux voilà
j'ai une gestion responsable je dis la
vérité aux mauriciens
mais on se lance dans des gros chantiers
en tout cas de restructurations pour
faire des économies mais aussi pour
améliorer quotidien des mots choisis
dans cette émission nous donnons
également la parole à la principale
liste d'opposition lors du scrutin
municipal au second tour c'est la liste
menée par michel chapa l'ancien adjoint
donc de l'ancien maire qui est arrivé en
deuxième position je vous laisse écouter
ce qu'ils pensent justement de votre
première année de mandat
bonjour là monsieur gary astier depuis
un an avec votre majorité vous avez
décidé d'appliquer à maurepas une
politique de rupture totale qui se
traduit par une brutalité de décision
par le mépris le mépris de ceux qui ne
pensent pas comme vous et le mépris de
ce qui a été fait avant vous et vous
n'hésitez pas utilisez le mensonge
tapageur pour appuyer cette politique
alors je voudrais vous demander si vous
allez continuer longtemps dans cette
voie ou si vous aller opérer un virage
salutaire vous avez commencé à briser le
lien social qui a été construit en
trente ans c'est bien dommage pour moi
pas qu'ils le méritent pas un pion total
niveaux sont assez dures en rupture
totale utilisation du mensonge
je le comprends parce qu ils étaient 25
ans dans la majorité et je pense que les
résultats les derniers résultats aux
élections départementales montrent le
contraire et leurs patients sont quand
même content j'étais candidat suppléant
au des élections départementales et ne
se fera pas et quand même été sanctionné
lourdement lui qui était tête de liste
et partenaires des ruptures totales de
faire table rase du passé justement
d'effacer tout ce qui a été réalisé
auparavant peut citer un exemple créé il
ya 40 ans l'office municipale des
loisirs et de la culture par exemple qui
a disparu l'office municipal des sports
aussi c'était changement vous avez opéré
dans la commune vous savez rien n'est
permanent sauf le changement on disait
héraclite et c'est pas parce qu'on
change les choses que c'est forcément
négatif quand les morlaisiens ont fait
le choix du renouveau c'était pour ainsi
que certaines choses changent et nous
avons souhaité pour ce qui est des
offices reprendre la main sur la vie
associative
cet intermédiaire en fait absolument
qu'était une assiette d association
paramunicipale et nous avons souhaité
reprendre la main pour créer un vrai
service vie associative pour être plus
proche des associations pourraient
prendre pour répondre à leurs besoins
c'est ça en fait ce que nous souhaitons
faire ça marche très très bien en ce
moment ça prend ça monte en puissance
mais la volonté à lait juste
augmenter ce ses liens avec le monde
associatif et on s'est engagé en tout
cas dans cette voie mais quelques
tensions parfois aussi par exemple avec
la fnaca fédération nationale des
anciens combattants en algérie maroc et
tunisie vous avez refusé de participer
le 19 mars à la commémoration du 53ème
anniversaire de la fin de la guerre
d'algérie ce qui se faisait auparavant
avec l'ancienne équipe oui voilà moi
j'ai des valeurs qui sont différentes la
date du 19 mars est une date qui divise
profondément les français j'ai eu
beaucoup de soutien après cette décision
notamment des nombreuses associations de
combattants en france et dans les
yvelines et de mer aux alentours toutes
les villes ne l'organisent pas mais en
tout cas j'ai fait le nécessaire pour
que la stèle sur nettoyer pour qu'ils
puissent commémorer eux mêmes leur leur
cérémonie mais je n'ai pas souhaité y
associer j'aurais préféré la date
du mois de décembre souhaité sur la part
jacques chirac qu'il y beaucoup moins la
france malgré tout va bien à maurepas
mais quelquefois ça coince un petit peu
c'est pas toujours facile non plus c'est
évidemment quand on prend des décisions
c'est pas toujours facile mais
il faut expliquer là où on va et le cap
qu'on a envie de tenir je fais les
choses avec le choeur avec mon équipe
pour améliorer la ville pour mieux
entretenir pour améliorer les résultats
de nos enfants c'est ça la volonté que
j'ai et il n'y a que ça qui m'anime la
polémique je la laisse de côté je la
laisse à ceux qui en sont experts moi je
suis là pour construire plus léger dans
cette idée du changement de la politique
autrement l'été dernier il ya eu un
classement qui a été établi par le site
i territoire et qui vous classe et
l'édile le plus actif des yvelines sur
twitter une façon de faire de la
politique autrement c'est vrai que
peut-être je n'incarne pas ma jeunesse à
vue je suis très connecté sur les
réseaux sociaux 44e au rang national des
maires les plus extrêmes régnant rester
dans le classement des dahlias voilà
donc non c'est un mot les réseaux
sociaux sont importants et ça permet
aussi d'avoir un lien direct avec eux
ses concitoyens et on en revient à
maurepas et à ses différents dossiers
dans le micro trottoir du du début on a
entendu une habitante parler de ce
projet de cinéma qui serait tombé à
l'eau finalement ce n'est pas le cas le
projet n'est pas mort et enterré la
commission nationale d'aménagement
cinématographique vient de donner donc
son feu vert ce sera du côté est du
village des loisirs et vous y êtes
favorable au projet de cinéma oui j'y
suis favorable pourquoi j'y suis
favorable parce que c'est un opérateur
privé qui va investir des millions
d'euros dans une zone qui en a besoin
sans argent public de la collectivité
c'est à dire que le cinéma ce qu'on soit
sur un terrain qui n'appartient pas à la
ville qui est également privée qui
appartient à immochan okocha et donc je
vois pas pourquoi je me poserai d'autant
plus que ça va redynamiser une zone qui
est en train de mourir doucement et
puisqu'on a des commérages à bell aliant
décoller oui parce que il y avait cette
locomotive qui était attendu et moi je
dis aussi à celles et ceux qui ne
souhaitent pas de cinéma sur la ville de
maurepas notamment mes opposants
politiques
qu'est ce qu'on fait à la place mais à
trois opposants politiques parce que ce
projet de cinéma
il était déjà sorti des cartons il ya
quelques temps où la ville d'ys avec 90
du projet au tout début il ya un autre
cinéma c'est celui des longs cours qui a
été rénovée et qui a réussi à tenir bon
malgré l'arrivée de l'ugc du multiplexe
sur saint quentin en yvelines et
forcément ils n'apprécient pas voir
arriver un nouveau cinéma est d'ailleurs
le maire d'elancourt à l'époque s'était
opposé à ce projet sur mord pas mais il
ne devrait pas parce que d'ailleurs la
commission la retenue c'est pour ça
qu'elle a validé ce projet qui était
porté par un opérateur privé pas par la
ville de maurepas et il ya une
complémentarité se dire que les
multiplexes qui va se construire au
village et aux loisirs est un multiplexe
de généralistes alors que le cinéma
d'elancourt est plutôt classée art et
dessert c'est au même vie salle 1700
fauteuil il ya aussi dans ce projet qui
a été tourné ces différents projets qui
ont été acceptées par la commission
nationale et éventuellement un projet
sur coignières elle projette plaisir
aussi qui a été évoquée versailles qui
doit revoir son offre en matière de
cinéma c'est beaucoup de cinéma sur ce
bassin plaisir aussi par exemple oui
sauf que c'est celui de maurepas qui est
acceptée en premier donc après
je ne sais pas ce qu'il en sera des
autres tout état de cause - quand voilà
moi je suis né à maurepas j'ai toujours
vécu à maurepas et j'ai toujours les
alliés aussi les scènes et j'allais au
ciné c'est tout âge et c'est 50 50 ans
et justin comment à l'époque et voilà
elle savait quoi c'est pas pour autant
que le signer sept a disparu au
contraire puisqu'ils ont créé une
troisième salle donc je ne crois pas
finalement à la disparition du ciné 7 au
contraire ce sont des clientèles
différentes et je pense que dans la zone
du village et loisirs il y a besoin
d'une locomotive et le cinéma répond à
ses attentes sinon qu'est ce qu'on fait
c'est la mort de cette zone et je ne
souhaite pas une friche industrielle ou
commerciale au village des loisirs on a
un opérateur qui va investir des
millions
culturellement économiquement savard a
également de rapporter de l'argent à la
ville de maurepas sans coup tu ne sens
rien côté du tout donc pourquoi refuser
autre dossier qui dévisse et celui de la
piscine le centre nautique que vous avez
dû fermer en urgence pour des raisons de
sécurité c'est la seconde question de
michel chat pas justement les
responsables de l'opposition sans
étiquette sur la ville
et la deuxième question concerne la
piscine je vous ai proposé 500 mille
euros de crédits pour des travaux de
réhabilitation une première phase qui
permettrait d'ouvrir la piscine cet été
allez vous prendre la décision de
réouvrir la piscine où allez-vous
laisser le centre nautique dépérir et
fermer définitivement
pour l'opposition socialiste également
conseil municipal mené par ismaïl à
vannes il parle d' instrumentalisation
de ce sujet de la piscine pour lui c'est
vers une fermeture définitive tout
simplement qu'on se dirige est ce que
c'est le cas alors mais où était-il
pendant 25 ans monsieur chat pas propose
cinq cent mille euros de travaux mais je
rappelle qu'il a quand même refusé à
l'époque avec son équipe les 700000
euros de travaux qui était prévu par
l'ancien haut dit de 2009 pourquoi qu'il
refusait et maintenant je devrais faire
ce qu'ils n'ont pas fait en 25 ans en
quelques semaines j'ai pris une mesure
provisoire se dire de fermer
l'équipement pour des mesures de
sécurité on ne transige pas avec la
sécurité du public maintenant je vais
commander une étude de faisabilité pour
savoir s'il faut réhabiliter totalement
cet équipement ou le détruire et le
reconstruire elle a été commandé cette
étude l'étoile est en cours elle est en
cours de pour l'instant c'est des grands
fermés pour le brancher jusqu'à nouvel
ordre il ya une date de réouverture
potentiel ou abba mania l'heure on verra
quand les travaux seront faits enfin
tout dépend de l'étude de phase i/ii
toutes les leçons pour cet été déjà pour
être très clair gestion du back office
est très impliqué et de toute façon même
si on avait engagé des travaux
maintenant il faut faire des marchés
publics il faut faire un appel d'offres
entre le délai qu'il faut c'est les
travaux se fassent donc ça se fait pas
en deux mois donc je ne peux pas faire
ce que mes prédécesseurs n'ont pas fait
pendant pendant 25 ans a tout de suite
d'ailleurs au passage j'ai reçu les élus
d'opposition pour leur annoncer la
décision que je prenais et ils m'ont
demandé de ne pas instrumentaliser
politiquement la situation et qu'elle
qu'ils ont qu'est ce qu'ils ont fait ils
ont fait le contraire donc ça montre
bien que moi je suis le maire de tous
les maux passe bien je garantis leur
sécurité je ne suis pas dans la
polémique et j'ai toujours dit je leur
dirai je le dis encore aujourd'hui il y
aura une piscine à maurepas ma volonté
de mer c'est qu'ils deviennent piscine
et maurepas il y aura une piscine en kit
à tout détruire ce qui existe déjà et à
reconstruire la confiance qu'on fait si
on fera bien totalement et que ça coûte
10 millions d'euros et qu'une nouvelle
piscine coûte 15 juin millions d'euros
on va se poser quand même des questions
puisqu'il faudra l'appui de la
communauté d'agglomération de secteurs
même ligne que vous allez rejoindre à
partir du mois de janvier 2016 vous en
avez discuté avec un michel laugier
l'actuel président de l'anah casque et
justement c'est à l'éventualité d'une
nouvelle piscine alors pas encore
personnellement vous arrivez dans
l'agglomération de saint quentin avec un
cinéma qui fait grincer des dents parce
que ça fait la concurrence sur elle en
cours et qu'en plus à l'époque
l'agglomération avait soutenu et financé
ce cinéma qui reçoit donc des des aides
publiques d'elancourt et vous arrivez
aussi avec une éventuelle piscine à
construire il ya une piscine à
réhabiliter ou à construire sa seule
l'étude nous le dira mais c'est un poids
en effet qui devra être abordé la
piscine de maurepas et déjà une piscine
intercommunale sur le papier puisque on
à 170 mille usagers parents
quarante mille scolaires dont 13 milles
de l encours et 6000 de quoi n'ayant
donc à la dg une vocation intercommunale
et puisque elancourt et coignières sont
dans la comédie d'agglomération de saint
quentin à partir du 1er janvier 2016 la
piscine de maurepas a une vocation
intercommunale tout à fait donc
l'agglomération est prête à mettre la
main à la poche on vous l'a certifié à
n'ont pas encore les éléments
négociations mais on peut dire je
poserai tout le monde pour que ce soit
le cas comme elancourt comme coignières
et puis elle région également il ya le
département et puis il faut attendre
surtout l'étude de faisabilité pour
savoir ce qu'ils vont nous dire sur
l'état du du centre nautique et les
travaux qu'il faut faire parce que
l'audit ne portait que sur le faux
plafond la charpente et non pas sur le
système hydraulique et les bassins qui
sait ça fesse
voilà donc c'est pas un petit sujet vous
parlez du département juste le
département qui fait plutôt des
économies en ce moment donc on imagine
qu'ils n'auront pas trop de budget pour
la région il faudra toute façon attendre
les élections de décembre avec
éventuellement une bascule de gauche à
droite fonction du résultat à la fin de
l'année pour les régionales
l'agglomération de 50 ans ce sera le
dernier sujet qui va nous intéresser
pour les dernières minutes de ce café
politique 1er janvier 2016 la ville de
maurepas ainsi que plaisir les clés
ville propre coignières rejoignent saint
quentin en yvelines pour faire une
agglomération 230 mille habitants c'est
une bonne chose
c'est positif pour nos repas oui c'est
plausible on a fait partie par le passé
de cet agglomérat tafer et 30 ans après
on y retourne ont envoyé le temps guen a
perdu de temps je pense que c'est une
perte de temps parce qu'on le voit avec
les villes qui ont font partie qui ont
su se dynamise et notamment dans leur
zone d'activité économique
dans la rénovation de leurs équipements
moi je récupère des équipements qui sont
dans un état lamentable et dans les
villes aux alentours qui font partie de
la caisse qui ils ont été financés grâce
à la communauté d'agglomération de saint
quentin donc je pense que c'est c'est
positif pour la ville parce que nous
sommes dans un même bassin de vie et
nous avons beaucoup de choses en commun
avec les villans 30 notamment avec
plaisir avec les clés villepreux et
coignières nous avons des projets
communs qu'il faudra porter ensemble au
sein d'un comité agglomération de saint
quentin comme d'ailleurs l'équipement
nautique puisque
plaisir et les clés et villepreux dans
leurs communes de l'agglomération une
piscine en commun donc je pense qu'il
faut qu'on apporte aussi ses sujets la
roue semble malgré tout l'agglomération
de saint quentin qui est à l'heure des
choix il faut faire des choix tout
simplement pour faire des économies il
faut faire des choix sur les compétences
il fallait supprimer certaines
compétences se serait lesquels vous qui
allait arriver au sein de
l'agglomération pour le moment on n'est
pas là mais j'imagine déjà oui car
derrière il ya des compétences
obligatoires et les compétences
optionnelles il faudra discuter de tout
ça il faudra discuter du pacte financier
également il faut que ce soit
gagnant-gagnant moi je refuse que les
impôts locaux augmentent il faut baisser
drastiquement la dépense publique et il
faut surtout surtout est ce assez
d'échecs des intercommunalités
depuis des années c'est la mutualisation
de nos services si on j'entre dans une
grande communauté d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines il faut qu'en
mutualisant nos services pour faire des
économies et améliorer le service public
merci grégory gary sié maire hervé de
maurepas prochain café politique le 16
mai d'ici là je retrouve chaque soir 18h
pour le journal à bientôt